no importa es una escena que se repite
constantemente desde hace años miles de
inmigrantes africanos suben en pateras
con la intención de alcanzar la costa
europea jugando así la vida en el
intento el más oscuro de estos episodios
fue en 2013 cuando al menos trescientas
68 personas murieron ahogadas frente a
la costa italiana algo que los
sobrevivientes del naufragio no han
olvidado no vengo aquí de vacaciones
nunca me vengo con el 3 de octubre y voy
a ver a mis hermanos y hermanas que
están aquí en el puerto donde murieron
vengo a verlos tan solo en los cinco
primeros meses de 2021 más de 13.000
migrantes fueron devueltos en altamar
por la guardia costera de libia tras un
acuerdo tácito de la unión europea con
estas autoridades para evitar llegadas
masivas con su vuelta al país magrebí la
vía de muchas de estas personas corre
peligro se arriesgan extorsiones de
mafias abusos e incluso a torturas las
principales rutas son desde túnez y
libia a la isla italiana de lampedusa
una peligrosa travesía que ya se ha
cobrado la vida de más de 1100 personas
este año una de las razones o la razón
principal de la que hay tantísimos
muertos haya mediterráneo central
realmente es la dejación de funciones de
las autoridades competentes con tal de
que no llegue gente a europa tanto a
malta como a italia se está silenciando
lo que sucede con el fin de que todo
esto se traduzca en devoluciones en
caliente de las que nadie sepa nada o
peor caso que la gente simplemente
desaparezca por el camino la mayoría de
estas personas huyen de los conflictos
en la hambruna y la pobreza de sus
países de origen